having to hear me mum screaming like a
wild banshee like a wild injured animal
down my phone
really upset me it uh
even to this day just thinking about it
upsets me because it's still raw as much
as i wanted to go home to my family i
had to take what was coming to me
and
horrible knowing that
i'm now going to prison for five years
for a crime i've not committed
nick dunn has lived through one of our
worst nightmares
locked up in a squalid foreign jail
thousands of miles from home for a crime
he didn't commit that's when it dawned
on us all we were not going to a
hospital we're actually going to a
prison
and that's when we all had to make our
phone calls back to our families but i
was like ma'am i'm getting arrested
i don't know when i'll be released i
don't know when i'll next speak to you
but i love you nick was one of six
british men working as security guards
on an anti-piracy ship in the indian
ocean in 2013.
they were charged with carrying
unlicensed weapons
and sentenced to five years in jail
when that cell door shuts at the end of
the night and you're locked in that cell
and
the turning of the keys
the
hairs standing on your back the cold
shiver down your spine
it all comes back
the memories of your family
the good times
the pain
the suffering
comes
nick would spend the next four years of
his life inside some of india's worst
prisons
full of violent criminals in oppressive
heat
battling sickness
he told me it was his military training
his life as a paratrooper in afghanistan
and iraq
that gave him the skills to survive in
you know interacting like playing chess
and stuff like that and just trying to
get by the days that's the best
way of coping making sure you're a bit
active
and you're not
sat festering in yourself because
it will
dawn on you and
you can lose your mind but like i say
you've got to keep grounded the
breakthrough finally came in 2017 when a
chennai appeal court acquitted the men
nick was finally free to return home
when that prison
them doors opened
and you're stepping out
and yeah
you know you're not going back in that
prison it's like
your heart feels like it's jumping out
your chest because you you want to
believe it but
in the back your mind you're thinking is
this a is this a trick
is this a trick is this
is this a mind game
and then you're getting into the embassy
vehicle and you're driving away and you
feel the aircon for the first time in
quite a long time you know
it's over
it's over
every day nick's memory of his living
hell
inside an indian prison
fades a little more
but he knows he will never
ever
be able to forget
his ordeal
ashish joshi
sky news